or des y rester vanité et est resté 0
merci voilà donc c'est ça les combats
suivis peu après vous mon instinct c'est
à dire à partir du moment où j'ai vu la
statuaire exprime sa et l'homme ne bouge
jamais à travers le temps il exprime
donc le sentiment par l'attitude par
l'immobilité donc en donnant ces
conventions on leur apprend à jouer
je trouve ça un sens c'est que soyez là
un mythe vous êtes en train d'apprendre
des jeunes il ya une chose en picardie
c'est le vrai la précoce et d'anvers
l'artiste quand il commence à être
révélé c'est dans la lumière
donc c'est pour ça que je trouve que
l'école est important parce que l
enseigne la grammaire de deux coups
étaient mous mètres et ceux du barreau
dois ma grammaire à moins dans ses
quarante ans de tournée le fait dans le
monde et les scream désir l'acrobatie la
danse classique la danse contemporaine
jazz et bien entendu le tient de verre
d'eau si l'on soumet la discipline
principale à ses effets la grammaire
variés du cou des mains il ya 250
positions de là donc c'est une
gymnastique aussi riches possèdent de la
danse saisissent pas la différence est
qu'à la danse est un grand art de
mouvement
deux pirouettes techniques et l'unim et
un art attitude mais un arbre très lié
au sol et michael jackson à lancions un
mais ça c'est une autre histoire quand
tu vois je ne savais pas en 88 quand il
est venu en france et bien je ne savais
pas qu'ils connaissaient marceau et
quand j'ai joué dans toutes les grandes
villes d'amérique anca en 81 78 75 déjà
il était venu sans que je sache et en 88
quand il est venu pour la première fois
en france pour faire son grand show il a
dit à deux personnes que je vais
rencontrer je pense qu'elle a dit
marlene dietrich et marcel marceau alors
on lui a demandé mais comment marcel
marceau il a dû parsemer parce que
marcel marceau pour moi c'est un exemple
c'est le cri silencieux et ça m'a
énormément inspiré et quand je les ai
vus faire la marche contre le vent j'ai
décidé de faire ce moulin et ensuite son
cri à lui c'est au fond le cri ce que je
donne avec le silence il le donne avec
l'émotion du mouvement et de danse parce
qu est un remarquable danseurs et alors
ils avis il faudrait qu'on travaille
ensemble et leur gestion de tourner en
argentine il était là-bas aussi il me
dit voilà est-ce qu'on pourrait faire à
chaud ensemble et je voudrais que vous
mettiez en scène miles of childhood
chaillot des zones qui est une très
belle chanson un peu un peu ribaudière
et baudelairien
et romantique à ce moment-là travailler
voilà voilà
il comptera bien entendu on l'a
travaillé et tout allait très bien la
presse est venue la télévision on était
pris ensemble on a fait ensemble marche
pour la vie est précieuse et what's the
smile marcel marceau et le lendemain
répétition générale il tombe révolte et
mais sans sourire comme il vient de le
faire
sa façon de marcher c'est très proche de
votre façon de oui parce qu'on voit nous
une piscine et lui fait le loup loi vous
savez le faire quand même
oui mais pas aussi bien mais maintenant
et je vais vous êtes en forme c'est
génial c'est fantastique
moi je trouve d'être un mythe vivant
comme ça et d'être en forme et de donner
des cours à des jeunes tout ça on
travaille là depuis deux heures après
l'oubli sans arrêter vous êtes bien la
pacha chez infor talent de chez un vieux
jeunes et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux